[Musica]
l tutti ragazzi benvenuti a questo video
sono fa vj prima di cominciare volevo
ringraziarvi di cuore la gaber che nello
scorso episodio di fornet che è andato
benissimo però in parte quello un sacco
di voi hanno utilizzato il mio codice
creatore e non pensavo perché ho detto a
me lo inserisco nel video invece tanti
di voi lo hanno utilizzato vi ringrazio
se volete supportarmi con il codice
creatore parigi è questo qui resto qua
che tiro su sempre con la magia
supportate vehicle codice catone fateci
tv se comprate skin europea gente del
suo forte
inserite il codice catore poi di tv e
siete più figli se arriviamo al 100 mila
supporter faccio il vino di four nights
è nudo
vi lascio al video ragazzi buona visione
allora ragazzi prima di partire volevo
ringraziare step e ferie perché mi hanno
regalato una skin in un loro video ma
non legato a sky poi andrò a veder me lo
vediamo subito cosa mi ha regalato dove
lo trasmette in realtà ci sono the gift
nissan anche i due che trova lì tu e io
interiore da stesso
ebbene io ne ho abbastanza strana ti
ringrazio per come l'hai scritto tu
trovato interiore sempre a grazie ai
proprio trovato uno script grazie la mia
vera amici belli la gente dovrebbe
essere bella tanti auguri a te tanti
auguri a per il mio compleanno
grazie al compleanno grazie va dai ti
piace o che bella sembro io versione
donna non è vero grazie mille ragazzi
bellissimo di chiudere più di va bene me
l'avete subito guarda voglio mettere per
nove social cactus si voglia mettere
l'altro voglio mettere quella che mi
regala lei o ragazzi le avremo bisogno
di tutto il mantra positivo che potremo
metterci perché stiamo per fare una citt
source e tutti noi sono le mappe più
facili di fort knight voglio morire
adesso ci sono subito le granate ad
impulsi quindi voglio già morire ragazzi
dietro in una zona quindi dobbiamo
ancora leggera su bene ragazzi video
finisce il quadro di questo allora
l'unica cosa che viene in mente è che
ogni volta che neri premiamo questo
bottone la parete riparte quindi crede
solo premo costantemente a grandi che
vai mai si felicita no perché dai e vai
perfetto ti lasciamo che a parlare
parkour chiamo arrivare alla fine lancio
di una granata sui piedi sì sì mi è
sembrato così pure la partenza c'è
ragazzi la partenza ceca è fermata sento
solo 0 0 per brava penso che quando
toccherà a me trovarsi sulla zona che vi
corre dietro te la puoi fare
se la puoi fare sì sì almo calmo amami a
fare qua fai ciò che ti ho insegnato
morire le mot perché è presente che
dicono sempre dei respiri questo senso
catturare l'energia della rivista sarà
l'ultimo non devi sbagliare all'ultimi
all'intimismo dai ragazzi non puoi non
puoi sbagliare non puoi si raccontano
nel segmento di stare calmo bado mio dio
ok mai fatto un pezzo molto bene
semplice ma che spiega non so cosa a te
ma cosa stai dicendo
abbiamo un problema di come sono delle
canoe cielo quasi ingerì quasi
incredibile io sono qua non dovrei farlo
o quasi che bello però quel livello
siccome è molto più semplice sì che
secondo massimo bellissimo così basta
che peccato
questo lo facciamo dagli dai si può fa
bello questo ha messo il difficile solo
all'inizio
12 10
ce l'ho fatta non ci credo che neanche
maestro o che le trappole
non l'ho preso subito c'è subito pace
subito vieni ti aspetto sei proprio
inalmente che riesce questa mi sembra
molto simpatica come cosa è l'unica cosa
che ho visto quando quando ho visto di
screenshot della mappa che più di una
cosa strana chiede di arrivare alla fine
io pensavo che avremmo rimbalzato anche
io credo che pensavo che hanno né
simpatico no devi semplicente schivarli
ma non è bastato a mio dio così fate
alla fine giuro ma per loro affidate
sono morte due catene rimbalzare come
una pallina paese dato come voi o no i
denti non devi saltare non saltare non
ho saltato pizzo che vada veramente
fortuna questo perché di sballo
dall'altro farlo senza toccarli tipo è
quello che volevo provare mai senso vero
c è un dramma così penso che si prende
il velino della gamba
mamma mia attenzione proprio lui no
l'ultimo non ci credo che vada a piedi
si cioè quasi sono quasi al ghiaccio
non siamo arrivati a piedi al ghiaccio a
me spetta che arrivò anche oggi però il
ghiaccio marino piano rimpatrio rifila
nobile ghiaccio nibile è la situazione
terribile di te
la sua teoria o pensavo di essere morto
nomi anch'io calini siamo circa a metà
finirà ma sto seguendo esattamente
quello che stai facendo tu non possiamo
sbagliare a cagà orribile
questo era terribile voglio anch'io
passato un calo ma su in calo la bravo
bravo qui qui come fatto farmi da parte
[Musica]
nel mentre che andavo non è finito a
sicet e poi oh mio dio posso dirti una
cosa mi e adesso questo te lo faccio
provare
ti spiego e poi ce ne andiamo
praticamente devi camminare sul muro
usando d'impulso c'è più nei tiri una
quando sta iniziando a scendere nei tiri
un'altra e consiglio di andare verso su
ok proviamo perfetto ha capito mamma mia
che macello di questo credo sia
terribile e che quindi il tasto e fa
sembrare la meccanica credo sia anche
semplice però è un bel dramma motivi io
l'ho sempre più potuto impossibile anche
il vaia il momento di provare anche
prima ragazzi orribile ragazzi abbiamo
37 37 pino mantova 40 sarà finita ieri
quando sei tentativi no
ha chiesto cosa che mi frega il palo
preso l'ho preso peso ma rimasto da
nonna e poi come successo due preso l'ho
preso premuto giochi poterci tutto non
ci credo ma si tolga d'altro lì noi c'è
un cippo intesa talento due sono io ti
butto giù tutto dai ci abbiamo provato
proprio l'ultima volta io quei sai e poi
ragazzi direi che per la denner grafico
però figo è molto bella e molto bella
molto mi dispiace solo che abbiamo messo
di colpo chiara daino e strano è che
l'abbiamo abbiamo messe contato il
cappio ieri erano che è strano il fatto
che abbiano messo contate delle cose
dove comunque nella cisl prepararci
anche un miliardo di volte
vabbè molto molto strano però mi è
piaciuto un sacco di ragazzi mentre
faccio il parkour e muoio miserabilmente
vi ringrazio per aver partecipato a
questo video grazie ferie per essere
stato al livello 1 tutto il video è
stato è stato veramente un casino noi ci
rivediamo come sempre un prossimo video
come si vede via canale anche viste in
ferie che lascia in descrizione usate in
supporti dietro con il codice mio e che
tale descrizione ci vediamo
[Musica]